نبدا في الخبر المتعلق بالمدير العام
لوزاره الصحه منير البرش والاصابه والقصف
الذي ادى الى استشهاد
ابنته نعم عبد القادر قبل قليل شنت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه غاره جويه
على منزل نزح اليه الدكتور منير البرش
مدير عام وزاره الصحه في غزه رفقه عائلته
وهو منزل شقيقته في جباليا هذا القصف
استهدف المنزل الذي نزح اليه ما ادى الى
اصابه الدكتور منير البرش بجروح نقل على
اثرها لتلقي العلاج في احد المراكز الطبيه
بعد اغلاق طبعا المستشفيات في الشمال
نتيجه القصف والحصار الاسرائيلي ايضا
الطواقم الطبيه تمكنت من انتشال جثمان
ابنته وهي طفله تبلغ من العمر 13 عاما وهي
حافظه لكتاب الله بالاضافه الى اي ابنه
شقيقته ايضا تم انتشالها قبل قليل وعمليات
البحث لازالت جاريه عن مفقودين اخرين بين
ركام هذا المنزل الذي دمرته الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه بشكل كامل على رؤوس
ساكنيه في منطقه جباليا شمالي القطاع
تتزامن هذه الغارات مع غارات مكثفه كثفت
طائرات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على عدد من
المنازل الماهوله في السكان في مختلف
مناطق قطاع غزه اخرها هي غاره اسرائيليه
استهدفت منزلا لعائله ظهير في منطقه رفح
الغربيه جنوبي القطاع اسفرت هذه الغاره
حتى هذه اللحظه عن استشهاد ثلاثه
فلسطينيين بينهم طفل رضيع بالاضافه الى
عشرات الجرحى الذين وصلوا الى المستشفى
الكويتي في رفح وجلهم من الاطفال والنساء
وبعض الاصابات تصفها المصادر الطبيه في
رفح بانها خطيره هنا في خانيونس ايضا غاره
اخرى اخرى استهدفت منزلا لعائله العقاد في
منطقه معن شرقي خانيونس اسفرت عن استشهاد
سته فلسطينيين واصابه اخرين بجروح
بالاضافه الى غاره اخرى ايضا استهدفت
منزلا ماهو بالسكان لعائله ابو عطيوي في
مخيم النصيرات ادت الى استشهاد سبعه
فلسطينيين واصابه اخرين نقلوا الى مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى في مدينه دير البلح لتلقي
العلاج الطائرات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بعد هدوء حذر شهدته مختلف المناطق في
القطاع لمده ساعتين تقريبا عاودت شن
غاراتها وكثفت من قصفها الجوي الذي يستهدف
المنازل الماهوله بالسكان ومجمل ضحاياه
طبعا هم من المدنيين وخاصه من الاطفال
والنساء خاصه مع ساعات الليل ودخول بدء
دخول المنخفض الجوي الذي تشهده مختلف
المناطق في القطاع هذه الحظ يرفع حصيله
الشهداء الى في مذ بدء الحرب الاسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه الى اكثر من
20,000 شهيد
14000 من الاطفال والنساء من بين الشهداء
بالاضافه الى 8000 مفقود وايضا اكثر من
52000 جريح بينهم 5000 جريح بحاجه ماسه
للعلاج بالخارج والسفر عبر معبر رفح منذ
بدايه الحرب لم يسمح سوى لنحو 400 جريح
فقط ب السفر من خلال معبر رفع للعلاج
بالخارج وسط امكانيات طبيه صعبه للغايه
وعدم قدره المستشفيات على استقبال هذه
الاعداد الهائله من الجرحى وخاصه المئات
الذين يتوافدون يوميا نتيجه تواصل الغارات
الجويه والقصف المدفعي على مختلف المناطق
في القطاع من شماله الى جنوبه تفضل حسب ما
يتوفر حتى الان من معلومات عن الوضعيه
الصحيه للدكتور منير البرش ما حجم الاصابه
التي اصابته
او تعرض
لها بحسب مصادرنا هي اصابه متوسطه نقل الى
احد النقاط الطبيه كما تعلمون فان في شمال
قطاع غزه لا يوجد اي مستشفى يعمل بعد خروج
مستشفى الاندونيسي عن العمل وكذلك تدمير
مستشفى كمال عدوان والحصار المضروب على
مستشفى العوده من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منذ عده ايام نقل الى احد
النقاط طبيه لتقديم الاسعافات الاوليه له
وجروحه متوسطه وما زال ايضا البحث جاري عن
باقي افراد عائلته بين ركام المنزل هو نزح
من منزله الى منزل شقيقته في جباليا ايضا
لكنه تعرض ل القصف وهو من الاطباء
والمسؤولين في وزاره الصحه الذين اصروا
على البقاء في المنطقه الشماليه لتقديم
الرعايه الطبيه وايضا الخدمات صحيه لمختلف
المستشفيات والمراكز الطبيه في المنطقه
الشماليه التي باتت بحاجه ماسه لمراكز
ونقاط طبيه وايضا تقديم اسعافات اوليه في
ظل الاعداد الكبيره من الجرحى نتيجه تواصل
القصف الجوي والمدفعي الكثيف منذ نحو 20
يوما ومخيم جباليه ومنطقه جبالي وايضا تل
الزعتر وبيت له وكافه المناطق الشماليه
تتعرض لقصف عنيف من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تحاول السيطره
تحديدا على مخيم جبالي والدخول الى عمقه
وبسط سيطرته عليه وايضا الدكتور هو كان
يقود ال الاشراف الطبي والصحي ايضا في
مجمع الشفاء الطبي وبعد اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال اليه لجا الى المنطقه الشماليه
لمواصله عمله في مختلف المرافق الطبيه
التابعه لوزاره الصحه وخاصه مستشفى
الاندونيسي وايضا في مركز مكز جبالي الطبي
الذي تعرض لقصف اسرائيلي اخرجه عن الخدمه
وايضا ادى الى احتراق وتدمير كافه سيارات
الاسعاف التي كانت تتواجد في هذا المركز
الصحي البسيط والمتواضع الذي كان هو
الوحيد الذي يقدم الرعايه الطبيه بعد ذلك
شنت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه غاره
جويه على منزل
عائله الدكتور منير البرش ما ادى الى
استشهاد ابنته وابنه شقيقته ايضا ووجود
عدد من المفقود بين ركام المنزل لازالت
فرق الدفاع المدني وايضا جيران هذا المنزل
مدمر يعملون على انتشال المفقودين من بين
ركام المنزل الذي تعرض للقصف بعدد من
الصواريخ من طائرات الاحتلال ننوه مؤمن
بان ما نشاهده في هذه
الصور هذا الجريح الذي كنا نشاهده الان
قبل قليل هو المدير العام لوزاره الصحه
الدكتور منير البرش الذي اصيب في غاره
اسرائيليه ادت الى اصابه عدد من افراد
اسرته واستشهاد ابنته وكذلك ابنه شقيقته
كما افادنا قبل قليل مراسل الجزيره مؤمن
الشرف اذا هذا هو الدكتور منير البرش كما
نشاهده في هذه الصور الخاصه للجزيره